there quand même quelque chose de voir
s'affaiblir allez je prends pas au cas
où les pointes quoi un coq à l'âne alors
donc un coca light et ben moi whisky
buvaient pas d'alcool et non désolé
c'est plus beau cadeau non plus
bouddhiste ah bah non je suis con ou
porter des chaussures et je décolle et
alors en fait t'es quoi toi je suis juif
face à rien à voir avec le fait qu'ils
boivent pas d'alcool mais je suis juif
israélien aux hébreux qua non non pas du
tout je suis juif ouais enfin c'est ce
qu'on appelle un israélite comme non
juifs en fin de set enfin je crois non
enfin wifo juifs
merci je juive quoi
voilà vous êtes juif d'accord voilà
exactement faut le dire faut pas avoir
honte
il en faut bon bah à votre à la vôtre